If you want to see a tragic preview, really,
of the voter suppression and catastrophic
disenfranchisement that we're going to see
in the November election.
Look no further than yesterday in Georgia.
Georgia, among some other states, had primary
elections yesterday.
And you may or may not even have heard that
elections were going on in local elections,
depending on what media sources you consume.
You may not even have been aware that there
were problems or that there were even elections
yesterday, but there were.
And this is really, truly a crisis level situation
where the United States looks much more like
the developing countries that are right wing
leaders often criticize.
Based on what our elections looked like yesterday,
we had people waiting in lines, hours and
hours long, outdoors in the heat, often wearing
masks because we are still, by the way, dealing
with the corona virus pandemic.
Of course, this was there were shortages of
ballots and this was all disproportionately
in the minority precincts, parts of the state
of Georgia, where the population is majority,
minority places that tend on average to vote
more for Democrats than they tend to vote
for Republicans.
And at some point, I mean, how many times
are we going to see the exact same story?
And the answer is probably many, sadly.
But we've been watching this four election
cycle after election cycle.
This happened back in Georgia back in 2018
in Georgia.
That was one separate.
Then Secretary of State Brian Kemp, a Republican,
was running for governor.
And as secretary of state, he oversaw his
own election.
Again, Stacey Abrams to be governor of Georgia.
Ultimately, one big surprise and widespread
allegations of the exact same type of voter
suppression, disenfranchisement, reduction
of polling places in disproportionately minority
and Democratic leaning areas.
It's the same game.
And the reason that Republicans are going
to aggressively push this in Georgia is that
Georgia is increasingly a contested state.
Now, I don't want to pretend like it's a battleground
state in any real sense right now presidentially.
For now, it's still a state that Trump is
likely going to win modestly, easily.
He's up in the polls about seven points right
now in Georgia.
He'll almost certainly win.
But the point is Georgia in local and state
elections is increasingly purple.
It's close enough for Trump that he's going
to have to spend some money there, which is
money he can't spend in two places.
He's going to spend it there instead of somewhere
else.
Back in 2016, Donald Trump only won Georgia
by five percentage points.
In the 2012 election, Mitt Romney had defeated
Barack Obama by eight in Georgia.
And again, it's the state and local races
are maybe suggestive of what we might see
in the future in Georgia, which is more of
a centrist lean than a hard right lean.
And Republicans are understandably very worried.
So we saw a preview yesterday in Georgia of
what we're going to see in a ton of places
in the fall.
This includes Florida, Ohio, Wisconsin.
Really, it's like every contested battleground
state that was important to Trump in 2016
that he can't really afford to lose without
putting his reelection at risk.
We are going to see this exact same thing.
Now, of course, lots of Georgia voters, you'll
be glad to know, had no problem at all voting
yesterday.
Voters who disproportionately vote in overwhelmingly
white precincts and they were widely reporting.
Listen, I showed up and voted in five minutes.
There was no line.
What are people complaining about?
And that's exactly the strategy.
Make it really easy for voters that are statistically
more likely to vote Republican to vote.
Make it much more difficult for voters that
at the aggregate, you know, broad mathematical
level are more likely to vote for Democrats.
And it's the same betrayal of Georgia voters
once again.
This is election rigging.
We have to stop using these softer terms like
there were reports of isolated irregularities.
Come on.
There were delays voting in some precincts.
Those are essentially gaslighting terms.
This is rigging because it's intentional.
It's calculated.
It's an effort to swing results by controlling
and manipulating and sort of molding who gets
to vote easily versus who's going to have
trouble voting.
So a few things have to happen.
First, we need as many nonprofit groups as
possible to be armed and ready to fight every
voter suppression attempt when they try to
reduce polling places, cut early voting hours,
put stricter guidelines for requesting an
absentee ballot purge voter rolls, as we've
seen done in a number of different states.
We need these nonprofit groups suing every
single time and gumming up any of these attempts
as much as possible.
That's number one.
Number two, anybody who can either vote early
or vote absentee should plan to vote early
and or vote absentee and should understand
what the process looks like.
Now, in some places, you will have access
to both an absentee ballot vote by mail and
early voting.
You will have your choice of the two.
In some places, it's one or the other, depending
on the absentee ballot rules or the early
voting rules.
So inform yourself about what is going on,
where you vote, the absentee ballot, you request
from the state ahead of time.
Some states are saying because of corona virus,
they'll send everybody an application for
an absentee ballot.
Others are looking at sending the ballots
themselves.
But the point is, the normal processes, you
request the ballot, you get it, you fill it
out, you mail it in.
That's it.
You're done.
OK.
Early voting is in-person voting depending
on the state.
Sometimes about three weeks before the Election
Day, in this case, November 3rd, early voting
will start.
It's usually limited locations like here in
Boston.
If I want to vote early, I can't vote in my
neighborhood.
I have to go to one of I think it's like five
or six locations, including City Hall all
the way downtown.
Find out where that is.
As many people as possible should take advantage
of whichever method is available in their
state and whatever is easier for you.
Now, one last thing.
The Georgia secretary of state says there
is going to be an investigation into what
happened yesterday.
Now, I really want you to understand how absurd
this is.
Brian Kemp was secretary of state in November
of 2018, and he ran the election in which
he was a candidate for governor.
And lo and behold, he won amidst allegations
of voter suppression.
Now, another secretary of state is going to
investigate voter suppression that he presided
over to help his own party.
It's a joke.
We are a joke.
It's got a bunch of e-mails yesterday and
today from European viewers saying what's
going on in the U.S. with your voting system?
How is this still a problem?
And one of the richest countries in the world.
And the answer is it's a problem by design.
We could solve this, but there isn't a problem.
If you ask the people that benefit from this
voter suppression, there are now calls.
It's just unbelievable.
There are calls for the U.S. to bring in United
Nations elections observers in November to
try to ensure that there are fair elections
in the United States.
This is how unreliable and pathetic our election
system is.
And we're going to see a lot more of it as
we get closer and closer
to November.